right this time and I'm eating chips
[Music]
okay so I made this video about why
Americans eat dessert for breakfast -
pancakes with hot syrup and butter and
in that video I said I would share with
you the non American breakfast I've
started eating if enough people
commented and let's just say enough
people commented for the past several
months I've been on this journey of
inviting different breakfast traditions
into my home and into my habits and
that's a hard thing to do but I've
officially done it and I want to share
it with you so I'm gonna share with you
my top three non American breakfast
tradition I want to see in the comments
if you have suggestions on other
breakfasts that I could try out that I'm
not mentioning here okay so leave those
in the comments for now let's get into
my breakfast enlightenment first up is
Japanese I went to Japan for the first
time in 2017 I was shooting an episode
of Vox borders and I had just taken a
14-hour flight I was totally delirious I
got off the flight I met up with my
fixer in Tokyo and it was morning time
and she was like you want to get
breakfast and I was like yeah sure so we
showed up to a place called Yoshi Noah
what I walk into this place I have no
idea what to order and my fixer is like
don't worry I'll order you something and
she did and before I knew it out came a
platter that looked like this it came
with rice and miso soup and a lightly
grilled salted salmon and a raw egg yes
a raw egg I kind of freaked out when I
saw the raw egg I was like why didn't
they cook the egg in their Salmonella in
this egg turns out in Japan they're just
a lot better about cleanliness and
quality control on their eggs not
surprisingly and because of that they
don't worry about Salmonella we do in
the United States so it turns out you
can eat a raw egg and I did and this
meal turned out to be one of the best
meals of my life
I ate it every day during that trip and
Here I am three years later trying to
reform my breakfast and where do I turn
but this meal
[Music]
turns out this meal is called tamago
kake Gohan which basically means egg on
rice and it is a very simple traditional
Japanese breakfast to recreate this I
went to a wonderful Japanese Korean
market near my home and I went shopping
for all of the goods first thing I did
was buy a rice cooker I didn't have a
rice cooker before and I found out that
a good rice cooker makes all of the
difference
second up good salmon I kind of just
throw some soy sauce on the salmon throw
it in the oven for 12 to 15 minutes and
then wrap it up and put it in my
refrigerator and I eat it all week so
now my mornings with Japanese breakfast
mean washing some rice throwing it in a
rice cooker pulling it out thirty
minutes later and putting on a piece of
salmon some sesame seed sometimes an
avocado oftentimes a lot of ginger and
all topped off with this amazing Hello
Kitty branded soy sauce that's like kind
of a morning tamago cockatiel Han sauce
that I found at this market it is
delicious it is unbelievably delicious
to have rice in the morning it's like
salty the salmon is salty the ginger is
amazing I put seaweed in it sometimes
and I like what I'm eating that I am
just a happy and happy human I also make
a big pot of miso soup on Sundays which
is a very easy soup you can throw like
six ingredients into a pot let it sort
of simmer for a bit and then you have
miso soup for the rest of the week oh
and for the raw egg I end up just taking
a high-quality American raw egg and
whipping it into the hot rice and it's
delicious and I've been eating it for
months now and I have not gotten sick so
you can do it too this food is so good
next up let's talk about Israel
Palestine
[Music]
okay listen too much of my life has
already been spent in the comment
section of videos reading and responding
to comments on videos that I make about
Israel Palestine today we're not talking
about the decades-old conflict where one
asymmetrical power is illegally
occupying the other oh geez I seen you
can't help it you just you can't help it
anyway today we're talking about
breakfast I was in Jerusalem in 2016
reporting on the conflict and I was
meeting up with an Israeli journalist
who I had met online wanted to hang out
with she told me to come to a breakfast
spot so I never get it to the breakfast
spot I parked and I looked and I
realized it was a hummus restaurant
hummus for breakfast I was a little
caught off guard because in my mind
hummus looked like this it was always
like the extra add-on that we would
bring in a picnic and in short I didn't
understand hummus during that trip I had
hummus of all kinds for breakfast in
West Jerusalem in East Jerusalem with
falafel with toppings of different types
of tahini with mushrooms man and every
Thomas was different and all of it was
delicious so fast forward three or four
years and I'm in my breakfast crisis
just genuinely do not want to wake up
and consume dessert for breakfast and I
decide that hummus is something I want
to invite into my home a little daunting
because I was like isn't hummus super
complicated to make turns out it's not
hummus is effectively just chickpeas and
tahini which is ground-up sesame seed
you can soak your own chickpeas which is
incredibly cheap or you can just buy pre
soaked canned chickpeas however you want
to do it basically what you're doing is
combining a bunch of ingredients into a
blender and just blending it up and you
have hummus and you have hummus for the
entire week and it is a perfect platform
to add anything - I've been adding feta
or an egg or pairing it with pickles and
beautiful bread I even tried my hand at
making pita bread for the first time
which is actually a pretty simple
straightforward bread I did it on a
griddle and in the oven as well both
fantastic I mean this is just amazing
food to have in the morning it's smooth
and light but also creamy for some
reason but it's not creamy like it
leaves you like wanting to take a nap
it's just just good food and now I make
a big pot of hummus at the beginning of
the week and we have it for the whole
week it stays good forever not actually
forever doesn't actually stay good
forever so like don't don't like eat it
after like two or three months anyway
hummus is amazing okay so the last
breakfast I want to talk about today
comes from Texas but really Mexico I
mean Texas was Mexico and Mexico was
Texas and then the u.s. stole it all in
anyway I'm making a video about that but
let's just talk about breakfast last
year we were at South by Southwest in
Austin as he was speaking and I was just
tagging along and eating a million tacos
one morning we walked up to this taco
truck
Veracruz all natural just saying the
name makes my mouth water
listen I've eaten a lot of tacos in my
life I lived in northern Mexico for two
years I ate a lot of tacos I continued
to eat tacos whenever I'm in that region
and yet this morning those tacos were
some of the best tacos I've ever had in
my life if not some of the best pieces
of food I've ever consumed the tacos
that better crews are called migas tacos
which is whipping scrambled eggs with
corn chips like like crushed up corn
chips and they kind of soften but they
retain their crunch and they just make
for this delicious stuffing to a taco
you can also add out Pastore which is
like pork and
which is delicious it's usually topped
with cilantro onion and of course topped
with your choice of delicious salsa all
of this wrapped in a freshly made thin
but fatty flour tortilla flour tortilla
the key to a delicious breakfast taco is
the flour tortilla I'm a big fan of corn
but a flour tortilla in the morning is
just amazing this food wakes you up it
fills you up and it just makes you happy
to be alive when you're eating it I know
that sounds super dramatic but I'm
telling you man I have a very strong
affinity to breakfast tacos inviting
this into my home was not a hard thing
to do because I've been making Mexican
inspired food for many years ever since
I live in Mexico and what I love about
it is it's simple food
it is eggs and chips and tortilla and
you could throw cheese on there and an
avocado okay so those are my three new
staples in my life Japanese hummus and
breakfast tacos I promise that tell you
which of these is my favorite and I have
to say that Japanese takes the cake cake
there's something about having rice in
the morning it just it fills you up it
stays with you for hours and I love
breakfast never thought I'd say it but I
freaking love breakfast so remember if
you haven't already go in the comments
and tell me if you have a non American
breakfast idea that I can start trying
out in my life give as much detail or a
link as possible I would love to see
what other people eat for breakfast all
of these ideas that I got came from just
casual interactions with people who live
in other countries who do have different
breakfast paradigms and I hope that
reading through the comments I can get
some more ideas so thanks for watching
hey before you go I want you to know
about Squarespace who help support and
sponsor this video today thank you
Squarespace Squarespace is a place where
you can build a website or a portfolio
or whatever you need to have a presence
on the Internet the big thing about
Squarespace is that it's easy yet
elegant meaning it takes just a few
minutes to get a website going and it's
incredibly customizable and yet it's
beautiful-looking and it's like very
tastefully done you've got all these
templates to choose from and it's
fantastic
not to mention under the hood you've got
all this powerful integration like email
marketing and social integration things
that are really important when you're
running a business you need them to run
smoothly Squarespace is really good at
this stuff so there's a link in my
description that if you click it it
helps support this channel but more
importantly it helps you get on your way
to creating a portfolio or website or
whatever you need and to get 10% off
your first purchase so you can go get a
free trial 10% off if you go click that
link
thank you Squarespace for sponsoring
this video and thank you all for
watching I'm just gonna keep making
videos and just there's a lot of stuff
to make videos about I probably should
get back to it so I'm just gonna get
back to my computer and keep making
videos like it be where's my computer
anyone okay see ya